the other name that you get linked up
with a lot and it's especially been
happening more because he's been in the
news colin kaepernick is that something
you're going to be addressing on the on
the podcast is there a story to address
there um I'll take my time with that
yeah that's money that I extremely I
respect extremely you actually care for
extremely I think it's an incredible
person the big braveness that he's
showing now I admire and I feel like I
maybe had something to do with it making
him feel bold enough to be the kind of
person he's become lately how did you do
that we had a great friendship great
connection and we talked a lot I'll say
that oh yeah okay I have a lot of
friends no one ever inspired me to not
stand during the national anthem I'm
working on it well I've had a few that
would inspire me to Neil just talking
about no I I do get linked to him a lot
because during the Tiger situation
someone saw some kind of social media by
the way good prey I should point out
something that you were like you were
like okay I had this plan with Tyga and
everyone I just if we ever got old if we
ever got exposed we would just tell
everybody that we were really good
friends oh she and then I was like hey
what about Colin Kaepernick and you're
like well I'll say we're just really
good friends like okay well that kind of
well explains that one away it how you
want it I can write Ryan probably
turning red gnarly no it's okay it was
very comfortable yeah yeah you look very
confident in your assertion but you do
you think you inspired him to do
inspired me I think even during the
situation that I was going through um
this was a person who made sure to keep
in contact with me and made sure to kind
of just make me feel like I could stand
up to anything and uh I think it was a
probably an important moment for him as
well to see how the world was reacting
to me and how people were kind of just
really trashing me and how I was still
trying my best to stand as tall and
represent and protect people I was had a
really extremely low point accept
frightened is that because it was after
the tiger stuff it was all I was a
frightened during the time I was I was
so afraid of what was happening I didn't
know what was going
like I said when you're dealing with
crisis management people contacting you
and attorneys and PR people and all that
all the media like every show out there
among TMZ mm when you want see all this
stuff happening and I'm just like what
in the world is going on any way that
I've ever met even from kindergarten was
trying to contact me it was just not a
fun time for me and I almost gave up to
the lawyer threaten you they couldn't
really threaten me well they threatened
Lainie
they threatened her that in the
beginning they threatened her if she
released any statements on my behalf to
protect my brand in my name that they
were going to sue her for millions of
dollars basically shut the [ __ ] up and
once they said that to her I saw those
emails I was like okay you [ __ ] with
the wrong one now I'm gonna do a press
conference because you don't threaten my
people you don't threat my friends you
don't do stuff like that and then they
started to understand that I wasn't
gonna be pushed around and then they
came the let's let's try to buy her
silence which he should have known that
that wouldn't have worked space no me
for years he knows bullying does not do
anything but piss me off he knows that I
didn't need the money you know like what
was I gonna I didn't you're already
label me an extortionist okay you're
letting it out there and and the public
eye that I am having a hold of this sex
tape and I'm trying to extort someone
that I care about so you're already
lighting that flown around in the media
and spin so that I'm the villain or the
yeah the villain and then privately
you're trying to please I'll do anything
you know just help us out just follow
whatever we want you to do and I'm like
why would I do that after you're out
there publicly changing my name and
that's what we want you to do is like
just agree with us tainting your name
yes that way I look good I was being
here like sorted right residentially so
that's when Colin helps you out so much
um he he just gave me confidence that I
didn't have during that time like he was
still a friend and wasn't afraid to
still contact me and wasn't afraid to
check on me and wasn't afraid to give me
some inspiration and wisdom and just
telling me that he was proud of me and
how I was handling it and that I wasn't
that girl out there outing someone did
you want did you find that certain
people contacted you because they just
wanted to make sure that that their
secret was safe did you get certain
people they would feel like that's it
would've been fake that
time when people were saying that I was
doing all these horrible things I don't
think anybody would have felt safe yeah
but did anybody like from your past call
you and be like you're not dying that
knows me knows I'm not capable of doing
things like you're not gonna do it's
just not who I am
yeah I've been in the industry for 12
years he's these are these are not the
only high-profile people have been in my
life do you ever dress